e
we'll go ahead and get started um we got
a couple of U folks testifying today
this is the uh subcommittee work session
on the dees rules update uh
progress uh we do have a quorum all
members are
present and the first thing I like to do
is um discuss the field trip for for
Friday um the last I got in my little
neck of the woods is 12 to 18 in
Thursday
afternoon and not only 12 to 18 but 12
to 18 heavy I don't get your snowblower
out after 6 Ines get it out after 1 inch
and so um I just soliciting feedback
from those in the room to push it uh uh
a week or two does that absolutely I
think that makes sense does that make
sense to everyone in the room agreed
okay um so I I'll coordinate with them
after this meeting to push it is there a
better date one or the
other um I think a Friday is a good day
yeah like to stick with a
Friday
and the 5th the 12th and the 19th what
we push it to the 19th and then maybe
we're hopefully through the worst of the
snow events uh it could be but I just
got to double check yeah
I
um looks
good yeah for and half yeah 19 okay U we
could look at the 19th is that good for
everyone you you can't make
it and what
about I I cannot do the 26 um then the
only next date is the third of May for
me um third of May would work I mean it
would be fine
it's third third of May or 19th those
are the two options
any dire preference can you make the
third of May
Arnie Kelly yeah
Nick yeah Fridays are generally good for
me all right
Kathy May three yeah ma' yes good okay I
I'll talk to uh Waste Management about
the 3 of May
versus this week okay
all right
good and then um up first um this week
we have Muriel Robinette from CX
environmental
Consulting uh and then Dees following uh
CX
ma'am here
there you go there you go now it is okay
good thank you very much I appreciate
the opportunity to be here um I
also created a small handout which I
think you
have uh a word about myself I'm a native
New Hampshire right and I can remember
going to our town dump to watch the
Bears on Saturday
morning um
it was a interesting experience because
every town had its own little
bump fast forward a little bit after
school college grad school Etc I ended
up moving back to New Hampshire and I
worked for the predecessor of the
Department of Environmental Services and
at that time it was called the water
supply and Pollution Control Commission
back in the early
80s and I remember talking with uh a Mr
Sweeney who was head of the solid waste
group at that time and being the the
newly hired hydrogeologist for the State
of New Hampshire to head the
hydrogeological investigation unit for
the
state um he he said you know we we're
learning we as a state we're learning a
couple of things one is that it's
probably not a good idea to put
landfills in a sand pit because
contamination migrates away pretty
easily and second of all we're learning
that Bedrock is not impermeable what a
surprise since so many of our water
supply Wells Drive their water out of
Bedrock fractured Bedrock it's a
resource it's something we have to
understand and
protect so I've been a a hydrogeological
consultant in this state for the last 40
years I've done a lot of Investigation
work I've also had to do a lot of
remediation and cleanup work I've had to
understand collect the data and figure
out how to clean up
contamination and so I'm pretty
passionate about how we deal with our
waste because our landfills thankfully
now are so much better better than what
we've ever ever ever had in the past but
we have a chance to do it right because
we don't have to have too
many we're luckily we're on a path with
our Solid Waste plan to reduce at the
source the amount of waste that New
Hampshire needs to to landfill that's
our our choice of Last Resort to put it
in a
landfill and we don't have to have many
landfills to meet our needs
so these rules that are being evaluated
and as director whimet told us here's
our opportunity to make them better to
make them more protective to make them
able to protect human health and the
environment so this is an excellent
excellent opportunity and I and I
appreciate the work of the department as
they try to balance what the needs are
within the state which
obviously are up for debate and what New
Hampshire as a state can provide for
locations for disposal of waste so I
look at these rules and I'm looking for
the additional protections because I
think that's important it's we know
better we know better and so we don't
need to create an area of contamination
for our grand grandchildren or a great
grandchildren to have to deal
with so let's dig into some of the
changes that they're
suggesting um the the biggest thing and
we've been talking about it for years
now in in this body as well as
scientifically is the fact
that
landfills create a lot of leachate they
create this contaminated liquid and we
do a wonderful job job engineering how
we manage and control and collect that
leee but we we have a weak link you've
heard the old term a chain is only as
strong as its weakest
link well we engineer the heck out of
where we dispose of the solid waste
liners and all sorts of of engineered
systems which allow us to protect that
envelope that pile of waste that we put
there and then we move it over to
another spot at the site and we handle
it we store it we offload it we we've
got it in pipelines we have it in force
Ms and that's not very protected it's
does not have the same kind of
engineering controls and systems that
are actual weight based envelope exists
with so therefore that's a weak Link in
our sites and it would be prudent if we
either number
one picked a site where if we had spills
or leaks from that waste handling area
it wouldn't go very far that would be
one way of handling it the other way of
handling it is whether or not you line
and
and test excuse me and create that same
sort of protective engineered envelope
in the area of your leate
infrastructure that's another op option
obviously so when we look at these rules
there are several points here that I I'd
like to point out as to my concerns as
to how we want to be protective of human
health in the environment one relates to
groundwater protection how many of us
can our water supply out of a Bedrock
well many many people do more than 50%
of our water supplies come out of these
private individual Wells and yet the EnV
804 um
02 uh
Clause Is Now drafted such that we're
only concerned about what's the
hydraulic contivity in the top five fet
of saturated material it's
silent on the issue of our Bedrock Water
Supplies now how could that
be why is the top five feet the only
thing that matters is it because maybe
there's something that's even
more I'm fine to have you interrupt me
as I'm going along it's up to up to you
so so I'm sorry go so uh ma'am if if you
don't mind to finish this first section
of your testimony and then we'll open it
up for questions and then move on to the
next section okay does that work for you
yes that's fine with me I'm I'm
discussing the very first one that that
I have highlighted
here so this this particular clause and
the
rules um currently is is not Quantified
as this um July 2014 current rules is
described it just basically says it
needs to be such that we can remediate
it prior to it arriving to a a water
body or to a water supply now they're
trying to quantify it and the the value
the hydraulic
contivity of what is being proposed is
that of sand and sand is what we use in
our leachate systems to facilitate flow
of waste water so it goes down into the
ground sand is very permeable sand
allows contaminants to move and and so
from my personal p uh perspective as a
hydrogeologist is like didn't we learn
anything from Mr Sweeny back in 1985
when he said we don't put landfills in a
sand pit uh and I appreciate that we
have all the engineered double line
triple Lin uh systems that are
protective of the waste itself but we
know that there is Lee releases that
occur we see it it's happening today and
therefore why would we want to put our
next landfill site in a sand
pit repres Murray let represented po go
first and okay Sor represent
so my first question is can you like
please speak to like how dangerous it is
that we're only um testing the first
like 20 or 30 feet underneath the site
so the new rules don't say anything
about whether the applicant needs to
make any effort to test like the aquafer
where um where nearby drinking Wells are
and all of that
um that's my biggest concern uh my
second biggest concern with how the
rules are right now the the um the rules
talk about the need for a
hydrogeological
evaluation of a site and it doesn't
specifically describe that it needs to
be a three dimensional evaluation it
doesn't note that all hydrographic units
have to be identified and
Quantified um it's it's somewhat vague
it just says you have to do a
hydrogeological study and and it's up to
the agency to determine when they have
enough information when it's
sufficient um I think this particular
piece of the rules was attempting to
Define some sort of a third dimension
some sort of AAP thing uh but five feet
is it doesn't is meaningless so I I
can't answer your question really well
on that um I I think it should
definitely require a full blown analysis
of the Water Supplies of the of the area
of the
site um yes ma'am go ahead so I I don't
have a water well now but I did for you
know a gazillion years living here in
New Hampshire I've um born and raised
here as well um can you tell me on
average um I used to work for Capital
well clean water Center so I'm very
familiar with um uh artisian Wells and
Drilling and all of that kind of stuff
uh you know on average what the depth is
uh
for a water well in the state yes in New
Hampshire the Department of
Environmental services keeps data um on
the water wells that are drilled in the
state and about 300 feet is pretty
pretty average thank you very much okay
representative Murray uh thank you Mr
chairing thank you for taking my
question so I wanted to go back to
Geometry for a minute and I'm thinking
in my head when we're talking about the
5T below the footprint I couldn't help
but think of of um two different visions
of either a trapezoid of some sort or a
cylinder right of the footprint and the
the base could look quite different and
so I'm thinking about the concentration
of materials right that could be at the
tallest point versus on the perimeter
where there's maybe not as much stuff
stacked up around on the landfill and
I'm curious to know whether or not the
density of the waist in the center
portion of what they're trying
to what what they're trying to get at
could be more toxic as we go this way
and then it Wicks outward so why would
we just say five feet directly
beneath the there are analyses that they
do in their design regarding the
stability of the base layer so that this
weight this material that's placed on it
doesn't create an unstable
situation the the system also is
designed and slop such that any liquids
in It All Drain to to low points and
then are collected and pumped off so the
the leachate is controlled Within These
envelopes of the of the footprint
so follow up if I may I I guess that's
to my point um why would just five feet
directly beneath however be sufficient
wouldn't we be concerned in the event of
a leak that there would be potential for
drift or migration out outside of the
footprint oh yes if if there is a leak
from the footprint of the landfill it
there's there's nothing to stop it at 5
feet or moving laterally away from the
footprint of the landfill the only thing
that really does is the site conditions
and if landfills were sighted in a silty
till material it doesn't want to go very
far and so that's gets back back to the
the sighting criteria that if we utilize
mother nature to help us contain any
releases that we may have it's not going
to go very far if it travels very very
slowly which was the whole point of
looking at at travel times to sensitive
receptors whether it was a a well or
river or a lake or some public water
supply thank you any other questions on
this area representative ger thank you
Mr chair thank you very much for taking
my question so as I understand that one
of the explanations for this distinction
between the insitu site right as opposed
to then the developed site and having
these what are demonstrably weaker
standards now for the insitu site is the
argument that this double
lined uh engineering is
certainly much better than unline but
but can you speak to how um how often we
see leaks even in double line facilities
I mean is this a is this a Panacea is
this a cure all or uh if we
have uh the the hydraulic conductivity
of The Institute site is not a place
where we would put a
landfill should we just rest assured
that having a double liner above that is
going to solve all of our
problems well I don't think we have a
lot of data in our tiny little state but
I know that the Environmental Protection
Agency has been looking at and
researching and
evaluating the the so-called
state-of-the-art double Lin landfill
systems all over the United States and
their conclusion is is that leaks
definitely do
occur um the what we've experienced
obviously in New Hampshire is the fact
that you know we handle a lot of leee it
rains here a lot in case we haven't all
noticed how much it rains and when
they're handling the waste and putting
it in the the cells and whatever we
create a lot of Lee and that leachate is
handled outside of the engineered
controlled areas and that is the weak
Link in our chain for a site that's
permeable I I if if we have to locate a
landfill in a sand pit again let's
listen to Mr Sweeny and say let's try
not to do it in the first place but if
we have to then we should have
engineered controls so that the leachate
handling area is as protected as as
engineered and monitored as much as the
actual waste disposal thank you very
much okay ma'am um if you don't mind
going on to your second point that would
be great yes yeah I'm certainly fine
with that um the second Point relates to
the whole issue of of a setback um our
rules currently say you know we need to
the the footprint of the landfill can't
be within 200 fet of a water body of any
perennial surface water body and I'm
reading from the column to the left and
then we have started to make a change
and said oh let's make it 500 ft well
500 ft is better than 200t but is that
enough and when you look at a hydraulic
conductivity possibly being allowed of 3
feet per day 500 feet doesn't even give
us a year before contamination
potentially could reach a a water body
so that's kind of close possibly too if
you're going to site in that sort of a
sand pit um now the rules are written so
we went back to 200 feet for first and
second order streams and then 500 ft for
everything else and my observation of
this is that it's pretty
meaningless to say any of these
distances 200 to 500 fee it's
meaningless because we're considering
allowing our next site possibly to be in
a sand pit so there's just not the time
sufficient to find and stop the releases
that can occur in an unprotected area if
you have surface water bodies that are
200 feet
away any
questions representative ger thank you
Mr chair uh and thank you again for
taking my question so the the question
that I have asked uh over and over again
kind of ad nauseum at this point is why
we're using feet instead of of some
travel time right so a three year five
year whatever n understand we've had
some discussion that uh the argument can
be made that that two or 500 feet on a
quote unquote average site equates to a
certain amount of travel time uh but
that is obviously not site specific
right I mean that's just an average
based upon what we know about sites Etc
but so do you have a view
on
whether uh it is better to have this
setback distance in terms of feet or in
terms of of travel
time it's my opinion that it definitely
should be travel time and it is in other
states um Fe feed are arbitrary unless
unless the state's going to decide
specifically
where sites are going to be acceptable
or not and and they know that 500 ft is
good that's something that can address
but I I really think travel time is the
way to go because that site specific and
it's not like we we locate 10 of these a
year we we locate one very seldom and
and carefully and and I know everybody
puts a lot of thought into it but um
these these arbitrary distances are
really meaningless thank you okay and
representative muray uh uh thank you Mr
chair I I did want to I'm referring back
to a document that the department had
put out on uh I believe
believe this would have been September
of 2017 and where they are classifying
stream
nominations and um it is and they talk
about stream orders being defined based
on the hierarchy of tributaries and one
of the things that they note is that
first order streams are Headwater
streams second order streams are formed
with the Confluence of two first order
streams so essentially it is putting two
first order streams together for a
second order stream and I guess I'm
confused as to why we would even be
considering um 200t for types
of primary bodies of water source any
any whether we're talking about first
second or third so I don't know um if
you can speak
to again I guess going back to both
representative gerana and uh
representative penza's questions about
why 200 ft would even be an appropriate
Choice well it's 200 fet now is is what
the rules say the ones that are in
existence and they and they don't
attempt to do anything about first order
second order third order whatever they
just see any
perennial water um body that's correct
and the the the version before drafted
on
10623 went to 500 and I
guess the conversation is perhaps in HB
56 is that correct we had initially
tried distance to travel is that correct
corre um and so now in the rules
drafting we're back to this conversation
around feet is what I guess I I I don't
know why it would change back you need
to ask the agency why they're thinking
they need to go back to less protective
because these rules in
general at least with respect to the
natural conditions are definitely
weakening as far as distances and
hydraulic
conductivities thank
you all right and final point please the
the final Point relates to the landfill
subgrade and base grade and again this
this is tied to the footprint it's tied
to the engineered areas and
they proposed at one time of having a a
a more stringent lower denser hydraulic
conductivity layer that would be
obviously a safeguard for any releases
through the the lined system and and
then it changed again back to 10 the
minus 4th instead of 10 to the minus 5th
um I guess I wouldn't understand why
we'd be going back if it's something
that we can engineer why not have it be
more more conservative why not have it
be more imper able um and let's require
it throughout the landfill site
including the infrastructure area
because that would help stop that
migration of contaminants that we know
are going to at some time where all
human could be released from the
site yes ma'am thank you thank you and
thank you for taking my
question a lot of this science is
unfamiliar to me but that last Point
makes perfect sense to me because I can
understand the fact that we need greater
protection rather than lesser and isn't
it true that other states have these
numbers that provide greater
protection yes they absolutely do some
even go to 10 the minus 7 cm per second
as a requirement and and if it's an
average doesn't that mean that other
parts of the site are going to
be more porous more less protective with
that number yes they they it can be less
protective in areas and so on average
it's right able to meet that standard
thank
you repr jam thank you Mr chair uh so
I'm going to ask uh because I'm an
academic you're an academic I'm G to ask
a big bigger kind of question and that
has to do with the geology of the state
one of the points of contention here is
is the idea that the stricted standards
somehow mean that you can never site a
landfill uh in the state of New
Hampshire when we talk about the the
requirements in Maine then again the
response is not only is this not Maine I
get that but that somehow the inference
seems to me that somehow New Hampshire
is dramatically geologically different
from Maine so that whereas they could
site a landfill at 10 to theg 5th in
Maine somehow it is not possible in New
Hampshire so could could you give us a a
very quick kind of lesson in in the
geology of the region because I do
understand like Vermont and and and New
Hampshire are significantly different
right geologically because of how the
land mass comes together so uh could
could you speak a little bit to the
underlying kind of geography geology in
New Hampshire how it compares to the
region as a whole and perhaps
specifically if possible to to
Maine one of the common denominators
that we have in New England is the fact
that we had a a continental glacier that
came down and the glacier certainly the
Bedrock and the different types of
sediments that make up the Bedrock are
different when you go from different
states and that's that is a a a definite
but what these rules are talking about
is all about the spicial geology it's
all about what soil what granula
material was laid down by the glacier
and its
meltwaters and the glacial lakes that
happened and there are actually great
similarities because this continent
Glacier when it came down out of Canada
created a layer of Basil till which is a
clayr silty heavy dense material that
smeared over our Bedrock features it
also carved out where the weak areas
were in the Rocks we end up with some
lovely Lakes such as you know Squam Lake
winaki
Etc and then when this big continental
glacier melted back it went all the way
down to Long Island and the whole island
of Long Island is really the end of a
glacier
um when it melted back it it is called o
blasion till and that's from the
meltwaters and we end up with these nice
little round Kettle holes because a big
chunk of ice melted in a spot and you
have the Sands and gravels deposited
around it but that till is still there
and the till is silty and it's low
permeability and it exists very much on
that north and west sides of all over of
our Hills they're called drumlins we
have them all in this state so does
Vermont so does
Maine and that has low permeability
material and we we don't have to site
landfills in oopy where we have this
nice sand and gravel uh oblan outwash
material we could choose to do it in
this
till and it's it's here all in New
England is it Michigan I mean anywhere
we've had these continental glaciers we
have that
material and we could use it to our
advantage if we choose
to may I follow up um yes one follow up
please thank you so is it safe to say
from that I appreciate that very much uh
that New Hampshire is not somehow
magically different from the region
around us in terms of our ability to
site landfills on appropriate soils I
don't think it's different I've worked
in Maine I've worked in Vermont New
Hampshire Massachusetts Connecticut
Rhode Island on
landfills so I don't see it as being an
outlier it's just our
choice thank you very much thank you Mr
chair all right and represented
poten so that kind of goes into my um
next question so um director whims had
told us in one of these other meetings
that um I would and this is quoting I
would seriously ly doubt that landfill
sighted and operated in Maine right now
meet a 10 to theg5 standard and then he
said I mean it's very unlikely so you've
obviously worked with landfill sighting
in Maine so do you think that um
director whimet is right that main has a
hundredfold Stricker standard than Dees
um proposed in January uh for us um but
that they don't enforce
it well my experience as a consultant in
Maine working for Central Maine Power
one of the major companies in Maine was
that we were absolutely held to that
standard um that was back in the
90s uh I can't directly answer that
question for today but I would think
that could be found out if that was an
important question for you just call The
Regulators okay thank you and any
further questions
ma'am thank you so much if you could
stick around for a bit in case we have
any followup I would appreciate that
okay I will thank thank you so
much and director whimet and Miss
McKenna
please that's
right yes absolutely okay so um welcome
and and again from the committee's
perspective our our sympathies and and
prayers are with you and your family
thank you for that I appreciate that
um so a couple of things if I could have
sent you a note but my my mind wasn't in
it um so if you could give us an update
on the timeline of so where you're at in
the processing sure um and then update
on any rules that have mod you that
you're considering modifying based on
your
last um draft
sure and then
um any response to the three things
we've been talking about this
morning and then finally I have um
representative Murray has a a question
she'd asked um it's not secret but it
skipped my mind so was what was your oh
incident reporting oh yeah incident
reporting okay um which we had talked
about earlier as part of a
separate deal but you guys are going to
work on it in the interum does that is
that okay does that make sense that
would be fine and over to you sir uh
thank you um Mr chairman members of the
subcommittee uh for the record my name
is Mike whimet I serve as director of
the waste management division for the
New Hampshire Department of
Environmental Services and I'm joined
this morning by uh leam McKenna who
serves as the bureau chief of our uh
Solid Waste Management Bureau and we're
uh pleased to be before for you this
morning uh so just to update you from
our last update um I believe we were
last here on March 6th and that was
shortly after we had uh been before our
Waste Management council with a proposed
uh set of the rules it was our second
time before the council um and then they
had met subsequent to that to um uh
express some concerns and it's and
submitted a letter to us which I think I
I discussed in in in the last meeting
here um so um on the heels of that
letter which expressed some significant
concerns of the waste management Council
regarding the potential impact of these
rules um we went back and and reviewed
those rules and we made some proposed
additional changes um where we're at
right now in the process is that that uh
proposed version of the rules we went
back to the Council on um uh March
21st and we with they so that was our
third time at the counc
and uh we uh submitted to them a
proposed draft of the rules which we
intend to to um enter into the formal
rulemaking process and so the first step
in that process is to uh make a request
for a fiscal impact statement from the
legislative budget assistant and I
believe that that is likely to happen
today or tomorrow that's just in in
process uh within the department but is
expected to go over um probably today or
tomorrow and then once that happens the
uh legislative budget assistant will
prepare a fiscal impact statement
that'll come back to us and then um if
they based on that we will then file a
rulemaking notice with the uh office of
legislative services and that will kick
off uh along with that rulemaking notice
that notice will
include scheduling of a public hearing
and and a date a date and time for a
public hearing we would hold that public
hearing hearing and then that would
likely be followed by uh a public
comment period where folks who could
could also submit written testimony with
respect to the rules and then we would
review that review the oral testimony
received ining the public hearing and
develop a final proposal which would
then be filed with the uh joint
legislative committee on administrative
rules that um given the the passage of
time here we are unlikely to meet our uh
July one deadline for finalizing the
rules however because we will have begun
the formal rulemaking process our
existing rules would remain in place um
as long as we were proceeding a pace um
with the formal rulemaking process so
our expectation on schedule right now is
that we would uh uh be filing a final
rule making um Proposal with the joint
legislative committee on administrative
rules probably sometime in June um and
that um or or July and that that would
get us to a meeting of that group in
July or August so that the rules would
be finalized um shortly thereafter it's
hard to I'm being a little bit uh uh uh
imprecise because I can't say for sure
what those dates will be but that's I
wanted to give the committee an idea of
what that schedule would look like so
that's where we're at at this point um
we did send to to the subcommittee
members and to representative kraton on
March 28th a copy of the rules the
proposed rules that we submitted and F
uh and presented to the council um back
in March or in on March 21st and um that
version includes it's it's a red we sent
two we sent the actual straightup clean
proposal but also a track changes copy
which includes the changes that were
proposed um since the February submitt
to the council
um but also um uh actually probably also
includes a few changes that were made
between the January and February
meetings so I apologize if that's
confusing but we've got so many dates
going here it's been a little bit
difficult to make sure we got the right
um you know we we strike out all the
changes that were made prior and then
include all the changes so it's a little
bit of a little bit muddled there but it
it still I think is a good record for
the subcommittee's use of the changes
that we've made at the very least since
that since that first January proposal
to the council so I hope that's that's
helpful in understanding where we're at
um there are uh you know I think the
that Redline version presents the best
opportunity for you to see what changes
and you know understand what those are
um I won't go over all of them there are
a handful of them that uh we made that I
that I can summarize and then if you
have questions about any of those or or
any of the other ones we we're certainly
willing to to entertain those um in uh
section
804 um
02c we adjusted that for clarity that
would allow the requirement to be more
readily implemented while remaining
protective by adding a depth to which
the requirement applies and and keep in
mind that um what we're doing then is
you know we're setting a floor we're
saying because the the regulated party's
got to look at this and say okay what is
it I have to do what do I have to show
so we have to set a floor that says
here's what at a minimum you need to
show and um I I would also note that the
change to the hydraulic conductivity
that was submitted in that section um
was proposed in the February draft of
the rules that was presented to the
council that was not changed more
recently that was changed between the
January and the February submittals just
for for reference
purposes one second please sure could we
just stop there for a moment and because
I think we want to take these from the
same sort of manner that we did with um
Miss Robinette okay and so if we can
talk sort of about the Institue soils
and the five foot change is that sure
yeah it's at the committee's pleasure
okay please um thank you so um thank you
for that um one of the things that I
would like to kind of focus on was what
I understand that insitu soil is
undisturbed
but what was the sort
of
thought behind adding immediately below
without respect to any sort of given
perimeter on the exterior of the
footprint um or a proposed site and I
guess I guess I am trying to understand
how five feet was the number that was
arrived
at well I mean these things are
difficult because you got to if you're
going to set a floor you got to you got
to pick a number right you got to you
got to say what does this apply to and
um
you know we do have geology that's very
variable it changes with depth and with
with laterally um I I'll try to address
your questions I guess in order um in
terms of the footprint the footprint of
the landfill is what we often use that's
the most important to us in terms of
understanding what are we building a
landfill on what is it you know if we do
have a release what is the first soils
that that that release sees so both in
terms of our design criteria as well as
sighting criteria with respect to in
situ soils we're looking to understand
what is beneath the footprint um it is
true that there are there are you know
in particular leech eight is managed and
storm water is managed outside the
footprint of the landfill and we do have
a number of Provisions in the rules that
that seek to make sure that that is
accomplished in as protective a manner
as possible um but from a practical
standpoint in terms of sighting um we
have to place some limits somewhere and
that's where the limits replaced um when
we do manage leech eight outside the
footprint we've improved the the rules
and the protection protectiveness of the
rules by uh requiring additional design
and Engineering criteria that make the
management and transportation and
handling of that leech safer follow for
a followup uh thank you I guess my
question is also somewhat around sort of
um even when you look at other things
outside of this department when you look
at building below uh a ground um Frost
heaving MH permeability of those types
of things movement in the ground um
there is a certain depth at which you
have to get to to prevent heaving of any
kind and I guess is there any concern
that an arbitrary number of five feet is
not achieving that and there could be
additional movement well separate and
apart from these criteria which are
really looking at the permeability of
the soils um we look at the overall um
strength of the soils and structural
Integrity of soils of the in place
formation um there's a obviously we want
to make sure that when a landfill is
designed and constructed and operated
that it's stable that it's not going to
have any kind of catastrophic failure as
a result of soils being um unsuitable
beneath it so that's part of the overall
review of the um hydrogeology of the of
the landfill and the GE and the geologic
setting so um that's I think the
strength the soils is a separate issue
really that's not really what this rule
is trying to get
to and um I I'm sorry I could we just
heard testimony that according to these
rules that we could be placing the
landfills on
Sand is that how would you respond to
that sure so and I understand that
concern I mean I think as um Miss
Robinette uh correctly pointed out we
have a set of rules now that doesn't set
a specific numerical standard it doesn't
set any specification for the quality of
those soils it has general information
saying that or or a general requirement
that is more about overall performance
that that basically reads that the
landfill needs to be cited in a location
where release can be monitored detected
monitored and addressed before it has an
adverse impact on on surface water that
part of the rule I want want to note is
still in there that that those that
language is still in there our
hydrogeologists and Engineers who are
reviewing an application can still use
that as a basis for making a
determination about whether citing of a
proposed landfill meets meets the rule
so that's I would suggest a belt and
suspenders over and above this minimum
floor criteria that that says you've got
to have you know uh uh soil that meets
the 5 time 10 the minus 3 standard
immediately beneath the landfill um so
the reality is that as as I think I
testified in an earlier meeting there
are a whole sort a whole set of criteria
that um someone who's looking to site
and construct a landfill needs to meet
some of them are about geology and about
setting um geologic setting but some of
them are other more practical
considerations you know is the is the
landfill located near major
transportation routes is it located in
an area where um it makes sense to cite
a landfill for the waste that it's going
to be be disposed of um there a whole
bunch of things that need to go into
that and as a result what we were
hearing and we heard some concerns
expressed from the council as well as
from the solid waste industry that um
that when you look at that sort of all
those criteria that need to come
together in order to identify a location
where you can site a landfill um what we
had originally been proposing was was
likely too stringent to really make that
practicable or cost effective and so um
we're we're look as Miss robinet
indicated what we're doing here is
trying to balance um making sure we end
up with a set of rules that is more
protective and I'm very confident that
this these rules are more protective
than the current rules that we have um
and also making sure that it's still
possible to site construct and operate a
landfill and to do so um in a manner
that provides for capacity for the
people of the state to have a place for
their waste to be disposed
of um one sec yes one second
representative pens I'm
sorry okay so I'm gonna have to read
this because I uh wrote this earlier so
um so realizing that the agency has now
weakened it's even weakest
one times 10 the -3 three times since
January so for example in February it
weakened it in two ways raising it a
fivefold more to 5 time 10 the3 but also
allowing the developer to meet the
Criterion on average which of course
means that part of the site could be far
more
porous even than this 15 feet per day
value which it you know just one aspect
of it doesn't meet that Criterion
because that's the whole point point of
making it weaker with average so as long
as the other parts were less so so then
in March it added the words for 5 feet
immediately below footprint which the
representative was talking about which
means that the first 5T of soil could
transmit liquid
downward in as little as eight hours
onethird of a day and then encounter
even more porous soil than
that how in any way could you guys
justify that except for having another
having a permit application in front of
you that these have changed to this
criteria well on the is first on the
issue of average the the average um
provision is in there because the
reality is that our our um geology is
not um not homogeneous there's there for
over a large site over you know a
landfill that might be proposed over I
don't know 25 50 acres um you're not
going to have necessarily at every
location and at every depth um the same
soil quality and so in many cases you
may have what amount to
meaningless variations in the soil
quality they're very small but that
there was some suggestion that if one
sample didn't meet a particular standard
then that would exclude the entire site
and that from a practical standpoint we
just didn't think that was really um a
meaningful provision and that would that
would be that would be helpful and so we
felt that average needed to be placed in
there and that that's going to mean that
you're going to need to have some soils
that are in many cases more protect more
less permeable but you might have a few
locations where small areas or lenses of
soils are a little bit more permeable
and that's just a a pract you know as a
regulator you need to be practical
enough to know that you can Implement a
rule in a way that does not um
essentially exclude every site from
being able to comply because of a small
imperfection in the or or inconsistency
in the soil quality so that's where the
issue of the average comes from um you
know we have um existing landfills in
the state that when they expand they are
required to meet the sighting criteria
um for that expansion because they're
expanding their footprint and the
expectation is is that we're going to
write rules that um everybody can and
will need to comply with and so um you
know there are the reality is that we do
have a number of landfills that are
cited in locations um that are not
perfect they're not um all 10 Theus 6 um
or 10 Theus 5 tight tills they're just
not and um that's the reality and that
goes again to that issue of well where
you know where do all those criteria
that need to come together to site a
landfill where do they intersect in a
way that allows you to sight a landfill
so we're setting a floor here it doesn't
mean that future sighted landfills if
there are any um aren't going to be um
you know aren't going to meet the
standard and go well beyond the standard
but we knew we do when we're writing
rules we need to have a floor that says
okay this is the minimum that you've got
to meet
and one followup
please um I appreciate your answer and I
think that what you just spoke on um is
so important why I think it's very
different than a landfill that is
currently active and um in in doing all
of the right things that is you know a
potential might expand at some point why
are their rules the exact same as
someone shouldn't they have separate
criteria versus we're literally citing
brand new there should be why aren't we
doing that what we should be doing that
we're spending all of this time on new
rules I believe there should be a a
cutout or a carve out for current
landfills in operation um in knowing
that because you're right nothing's
perfect I just think that when we have
something that is so
non-restrictive or nonprotective Ive um
that you could basically look at this
and almost sight a landfill anywhere I
understand it it's not specific there
could be one piece of the um you know of
the property that is uh pores or
whatever that's not good um soil but to
me it's it's two separate things this is
you know new sighting landfill should be
separately from somebody's that's
looking for an expansion why aren't we
looking at that the the department has
there's a lot of other departments that
do the department has approached these
rules and it's certainly the case for
landfills that have already been
designed and constructed and are
operating and there are many examples in
these rules where we impose a new design
or construction or operation Criterion
that simply can't be met for that
existing landfill and we do make
provision for that in the rules because
that's only fair but we believe that
when a landfill is going to be expanded
when its footprint is going to be
expanded that the people who live in
that Community deserve the same
protections of sighting design um and
and and
construction of anybody that might live
in an area where a new landfill is going
to be cited we don't believe that
because they happen to have a landfill
in their Community they don't deserve
the same protections with respect to
expansion of that facility so what we're
trying to do here is write rules that um
are and I believe we've succeeded we're
we're writing rules that are protective
that can be protective of the
environment of groundwater and surface
water quality and of people living near
a facility whether that facility is
already existing and wants to expand or
whether it's a brand new Greenfield site
where someone wants to propose a new
landfill representative H Haskins thank
you and thank you for taking my
question all along as we've been talking
about this I have had a concern that the
regulated Community as you refer to
them is is responsible for why these
rules are
weakening uh that never made any sense
to me is that the way the sausage is
made I don't know but as as a legislator
bound Duty bound to protect the
public I can't see that the regulated
Community should be the ones that design
these rules to be weaker than they
should be and even initially look like
they could be can you explain that to me
so the regulated Community does not
design the rules they don't write the
rules um they are a part of the group of
folks that we speak to because they and
that's true with all of our rules across
the department and it is the case that
you know there are areas the rules that
we we try to write things things that
maybe this committee is not even
interested in where we just got it wrong
where we misunderstood something about
the way the facilities are operated or
the way they're they're they're designed
and so you know we we believe we're
pretty good Regulators we do a good job
regulating these facilities but we do
not design construct and operate
landfills the regulated Community does
and so their input is important to us we
need to hear from them the same way we
hear from other members of the community
and the public and we've met with groups
of of all stripes with regard to these
rules um but we we do have a respons
ability to listen to what their concerns
are and evaluate them objectively and
understand whether in some cases we may
have it wrong or we or we need to amend
what we're looking to propose so there
are examples of where they have raised
concerns to us um we've we have uh you
know the waste management Council has
raised concerns to
us that that were informed by input from
the regulated community and we've looked
at those objectively and very carefully
and we've worked to really make make
sure that if we propose a change there
is a basis for it that it makes sense
there's a reason to do it that is um
that that serves the public at large and
serves Public Safety and Environmental
Protection um and that so they're all I
can say is they are they have a place at
the table of the public of of the
broader public for us to just ignore
what they have to say because they're
the regulated Community I think would
cause us to make a lot of errors and we
wouldn't be willing to do that one quick
follow um let um let's get to
representative Murray got three
minutes um go ahead um thank you um
thank you Mr Shar and thank you to the
department I I want to thank you for the
inclusion and reference to um Solid
Waste uh EnV
105.9 which was with respect to um the
notice of
um incident reporting mhm um and with
that I I did take a chance to go back
and take a look at I know that we are
not sort of rewriting those but I I
would hope that the department would
have an opportunity to have a
conversation with me about how those um
1,000 rules currently read sure um I had
taken a look at I I think there was a
conversation in the language there that
says as soon as practicable um I do
share some concerns with that language
and feel that it is a little bit of a
squishy sort of um open to
interpretation as to what that means and
um I don't know if it would be an
appropriate opportunity to have that
conversation today or um I do have
thoughts so I'm whatever sure you worked
on that do you want to speak I'm gonna
ask Leah to speak to that sure good
morning everyone again leam McKenna uh
Bureau administrator of theway
management Bureau uh we did just um
reopt that set of rules en vsw 1,000 I
will tell you with certainty we plan to
open that set of rules back up again in
the very near future I would love to
hear hear from you on thoughts to uh
strengthen 1509 we have some thoughts at
the department as well wmbr rules de.
nh.gov send us an email and we will
certainly engage on that top absolutely
I think that there are some things just
given the modern sort of where we are
electronically um the ability to
communicate with folks I have a lot of
thoughts about how those rules are
written and I would love to continue
that dialogue and strengthen them
because I do feel like there are some
areas there that are open to
interpretation that I am not comfortable
with very happy to talk to you about
that thank you and representative H
Haskins yes um thank you
and so I appreciate the challenge that
is before you I don't know if 10 years
ago when the rules were updated there
was a permit application sitting on your
desk um but that's the situation we have
now which complicates things I think the
public that we represent wants to know
not only will they be heard but what
they have to say in terms of concern
will be every bit as important and
will'll find its way into the updated
rules as Miss robinet said We Know
Better
and Maya Angelou's statement was when we
know better we do better and that's what
we're looking for thank
you okay so thank you so much um I don't
have a question I
just okay in one and a half seconds so
yeah um so there was a lot of
information that um you weren't able to
get to and uh I know that representative
ger had um some questions so could you
please follow up with um with us in
answering some of those questions in
writing um that were sent to you before
this meeting um yeah so I think are are
you speaking to the original set of
rules that still had outstanding or
excuse me questions that we still had
outstanding questions on that were
around some of the um continued changes
with regard to the I'm talking about
after the ma March 6th meeting um
representative ger asked for five
examples things like yeah I don't I
don't have it we don't have any of that
and you guys asked okay so I didn't put
any more questions forward but I didn't
I haven't received anything bear with me
one
second let me see those questions and
then we'll forward them officially no
they were already forwarded oh so it's
these questions
here that would these are the ones these
are the only things we forwarded to
them from the last meeting which I
didn't give you any questions there was
another set of questions that were
forwarded okay so I never got another
set of questions I'm glad to forward
them but if I don't get them I can't
forward
them let me check with him then that's
what I I thought there was something
sent over unless they received a certain
we'll sort it out okay um I would like
like to have another committee meeting
we talked about the 3rd of May going to
the Waste Management Facility so
potentially the Tuesday after that is
that is that okay with everyone at same
time nine
o'clock what's that date uh stand
by it would be um the
7th or the I I cannot do the seventh the
sixth six or 8th is fine of
May sth would be preferable let's just
keep it on Tuesdays because we normally
meet I understand that but does that not
work for you I I have a client that
day
uh let me check and see if I can move
that but want to go to the or we could
do the 14th 14th is
open okay any any obviously with the
agency will will endeavor to make itself
available to the subcommittee I would
note at this point we're we're entering
the formal Ru making process yeah the
very first official thing that's going
to happen from a public I mean it's all
public the rulemaking notice will be
published and that will be essentially
what we presented to the council at this
past at the last meeting um and then the
really the next milestone in the process
is the public hearing and comment period
we will not have rev rules to present to
you wouldn't be appropriate for us to
have a rulemaking notice out there and
then talk about proposed changes to that
rul making to that that date I'm sorry
you just went through it but sure yeah I
didn't give you a date for the hearing
do do you have a sense when it's likely
to be so so things get a little get a
little mushy now because things kind of
uh a lot of different folks get involved
we anticipate having a public Hearing in
the month of May and the public comment
period would extend for some we should
have if we're going to have one last
meeting before that needs to be before
that
date well I I guess what I'm wondering
is what what do we talk about at that
meeting because um we're going to again
we're going to file a rulemaking notice
that's going to have that initial
proposal and we're not going to be
making I mean we're not going to stop
thinking about it but we're not going to
be making any public recommendations for
changes right until and I mean the the
next for us in this rule making process
the next really important period where
we're going to be looking at public
comment and and making considerations of
change making changes from this initial
proposal to the final proposal is after
we get that oral comment and that
written comment and we have a chance to
review it so I I just don't want to
disappoint you if I don't want to come
and say well I got nothing to say
sub um Mr chair and uh for a moment if I
can just um nothing precludes us from
also providing testimony during that
public comment period so we could
perhaps draft some of our thoughts as
the subcommittee and submit those during
that time I believe that that would be
an appropriate Avenue for the
subcommittee yeah we would very much
encourage that and represent
poens so basically we've had all of
these meetings right we've expressed a
whole bunch of concerns and questions
and all of that and at this point none
of those have been applied the any
everything that's happened is weaker
weaker and weaker and unfortunately um
the waste management council is pretty
much 90% industry and that's who you
guys are hearing from in making those
determinations
so I just I I guess I don't understand
because nothing even if we have another
meeting it's not like you guys are going
to take all of these things that we've
brought up and and the experts that
we've had in here and and and go back
correct you're not going to be going
back you've gone weaker three times so
are you're not going to be doing
anything different so are we going to
expect anything
different well I I guess just to respond
to your first comment um I believe that
that these rules are far superior to the
existing set of rules that we have they
are more protective in many respects and
I also believe that our decisions about
what this current initial proposal looks
like have absolutely been influenced by
everyone that we've spoken with and very
much so including this subcommittee now
there may be disappointments for
individual members of the subcommittee
on specific areas that you wish that the
agency had drafted a different way and I
understand that and I respect that but I
will tell you that we've been listening
to you all along and everything all the
decisions we've made about the content
of this initial proposal have been
informed by your input okay so what what
I would like to do and that's a to to
representative penza's
Point
um if
on
uh I would like to hold another sub
commmittee
meeting uh I will forward you questions
that representative
jamana
has I I will verify that he has those
questions to get them to you but more
specifically I would like to hear
exactly how these are more stringent
than
previous so where our input is and and
that's and to represent hins point so if
you could just describe to us how our
input in this discussion has improved
the ru making process in terms of
protection and how these rules
today that that you have written are
more because there are members in the
committee that don't see it and so
clearly we should be a mouthpiece for
the
state saying they we're doing a good job
we are being more protective but if we
in this committee after many hours of
discussion don't see that then that is
that's concerning to
me thank you for those comments
represent Kon I want to note that you
know um a lot of this has to do with
what has happened in time right so we um
we've been thinking about these rules
for a really long time our you know
Engineers have been going along doing
their work um processing permit
applications regulating facilities doing
inspections dealing with facilities when
things go wrong and so they're always
thinking you know Ru making for us is a
is a is a full-time job all the time if
we're not writing rules we're thinking
about how they need to be amended and um
so the rules package that came out in
the fall was informed by by um uh a
whole bunch by that all that all that
sort of institutional knowledge of our
staff and and what we've been
experiencing it was informed by um a a
robust public participation process that
started last March and went through to
this fall um and so there were areas
that were um you know significantly
changed that that would you know
arguably would be very protective um
that were influenced by of that so then
we got there but then when you know when
folks started looking at them more
critically and the rules started to kind
of take shape and really gel then we did
receive a lot of concerns about the
Practical ability to implement those
rules so it is certainly true that there
are some areas that could be perceived
as having been really protective in the
original draft that have been changed um
in in in in response to concerns about
the actual implementability of them or
the or the potential ad impacts of
trying to implement those so it's going
to be the CA and this is what happens
with any rul making um it's going to be
the case that in
those months leading up to finally
filing an initial proposal you're likely
to see some things that that may soften
some very difficult or or um uh rigorous
requirements that doesn't mean that and
when I say that we've been informed by
that we we may be looking at comments
you know the one member of Industry may
say well we don't think that rule should
apply at all and someone at this table
may say well we think not only should it
apply it should be even more stringent
and we land somewhere where we think we
balanced the legitimate concerns of a
party who doesn't like the rule at all
and the legitimate concerns of this
group are others who want it to be as
protective as possible and we land
somewhere so when I say it's been
influenced that's the kind of primary
influence I'm talking about I completely
understand I I got you I'm all over it
you guys do this every day we do this
once a month and and you guys have been
doing it your whole lives and and we
have it I completely respect
that what I would like to
see
is a
description of the rules 10 years
ago versus the 21 March
rules and how the 21 March rules
protect the environment
better than the rules of 10 years
ago and it doesn't have to be at nauseum
it's top 10 top five something that
something we can look at and we can say
yes this process is in fact protecting
our
environment and balancing I I completely
understand the the the requirement for
balance and I understand that if you say
it's got to be a sheet of metal
underneath there that nothing can ever
get through that's stainless steel it'll
never happen so it's something between
stainless steel and sand but what we owe
to our
constituents is the ability to go back
and say yes this process is protecting
our environment it is helping to
prevent those activities that happened
in the past and that the rules that
we've created through this process are
in
fact protecting the public
from these these dangers and and
improving on a system that you know that
that needs to be improved sure so that
that's what I'm asking I think we can
prepare for you a summary that looks
like that you know a top 10 or whatever
I don't know how many it'll be but
basically yeah I don't need every te and
every dot crossed what I need to know I
got to have something I can go back to
my constituent and say
hey these guys are doing a great job
they've made some comp ises here here
and here but at the end of the day it's
much more protective than what we had
before we can certainly highlight the
key Provisions that have added
protections and we're happy to do that
okay all right good we're 15 minutes
over so I'm going to
adjourn um but thank you so much
everyone for your testimony your time
and and your uh input thank you thank
you
e